now new analysis suggests the bill for
repairing roads in English the world
because of potholes potholes could be 14
billion pounds in the next two years at
several times more than the 4.4 billion
currently spend annually by councils on
transporting highways well local
councils have warned that the cost of
repairs could see 2017 become a tipping
point for tackling potholes perhaps
unsurprisingly and let's get more all
this and win a mark so we sent out the
Maidstone this morning and presumably
you have found us a good pothole villain
doing my best guys and I just want to
express some skepticism about those
numbers you've got an industry trade
body that's the asphalt industry
alliance releasing a survey every year
the last numbers came out in March they
mentioned that currently the country
local government is spending 12 billion
pounds a year they're projecting it up
to 14 that is based on some quite
selective data i should add however
we're in a small village just outside
maidstone as you mentioned i'm very
happy to say that we're joined by david
murray from cycling UK cyclists clearly
on the front line of the pothole problem
in the UK what difference does it make
to have potholes on your journey to work
for instance versus not it makes such a
difference because when it wouldn't you
find yourself on a road that's
absolutely riddled with potholes we're
spending so much more of your time
concentrating on the road rather than
necessary the traffic that's with you so
that experience it's not just about a
comfy right it's actually about a safe
ride so whilst those statistics might
not be necessarily a clear reflection we
know that from studies through
Parliament just before Christmas but the
number of killed and seriously injured
on our roads who are cycling because of
poorly maintained roads is still a big
issue and one that needs to be fixed so
cycling UK really does want to see those
potholes found and fixed which is why
we've got an app called fill that hole
that fill that hold it all got UK which
helps anybody motorists and cyclists
they like to be able to report those
potholes quickly and get them fixed as
quickly too now when you live in this
area you live just a mile up the road
you mentioned to me when you go into the
local station to go to work or whatever
it is what are you thinking about your
local council what they need to do
better when it comes
too is it about finding these potholders
about repairing them quickly the Local
Government Association saying that it
could be 10 14 years in some parts of
the country for them to catch up with
the backlog of potholes do you
understand the pressure they're under
from central government in terms of the
funding problem yeah I do and
unfortunately it doesn't take very long
to head out from your door wherever you
are in the country to find a pothole on
the on your road so that issue of trying
to find and fix those potholes quickly
is a big problem and of course the
pressure on local government is that
those funds are still seem to be
shrinking and they are scrabbling around
to find the cash to get them fixed but
problem is an inherent problem wherever
there's rain and freeze on our roads we
will see potholes it's an issue that has
to be fixed and indeed clearly when we
have cold weather and we're actually
reporting live from salts lane to start
side maidstone back to you guys in the
studio